hey TV fans i'm leanna killer and before
you descend into your Netflix
binge-watching we are catching you up on
everything you need to know and remember
about Marvel's Luke Cage Mike Colter
made his amazing debut as Luke Cage in
the first season of jessica jones
appearing in seven out of the 13
episodes and now it's time for the fan
favorite hero for hire to start in his
own Marvel series but first a little bit
on his comic book past Luke Cage was
first launched into the Marvel Universe
in 1972 and he was one of the first
african-american superheroes to star in
his own solo title as for his backstory
Luke Cage whose real name is Carl Lucas
was born and raised in harlem new york
Luke was imprisoned for a crime that he
did not commit and while serving his
sentence he was forced to participate in
secret experiments which ended up giving
him superhuman strength and unbreakable
skin experiments bad superpowers good I
think it all worked out and when we met
Luke in Jessica Jones we actually
discovered that Luke and Jessica have a
really twisted tangled past so here's
how it all went down Jessica first
started spying on Luke because she was
actually feeling guilty cuz as it turns
out Jessica killed Luke's wife Riva
Connors but okay before you jump to
assumptions Jessica was under the
influence at kilgrave's mind control and
didn't know what she was doing even
though Jessica knew that she actually
killed Luke's wife she didn't tell him
right away and instead the to develop
their own super steamy hookup filled
relationship and even though she was
omitting the truth when I'm mad about it
have you seen their sex scenes and then
as we found out at the end of the season
kilgrave had been controlling Luke Cage
the entire time and he was about to kill
Jessica until she took a giant shotgun
and shot him point-blank in the face
luckily thanks to Luke's amazing
unbreakable skin he was unharmed pretty
much by the end of the series Claire
temple yes the very same nurse from
Marvel's daredevil came to Luke's rescue
and patched him all up but before he and
Jessica could resolve their issues he
disappeared and now with the premiere of
Marvel's Luke Cage we have so much to
look forward to not only are we going to
get to see luke cage's origin story
episode far we're also going to get to
know Luke friends and foes in Harlem and
find out how he becomes a hero for hire
until eventually in 2017 we are going to
see daredevil Jessica Jones Luke Cage
and Iron Fist all team up to be Marvel's
defenders so for now luke and jessica
has nothing to do with one another they
are just two people with a lot of
baggage who happened to have really
really really insane chemistry together
it's entirely likely that this could
change in the future because spoiler
alert they get married in the comics but
for now we'll have to wait and see what
happens Oh in our favorite fact about
Luke Cage yeah he has a catchphrase
sweet Christmas all right comic book
fans let's talk it out what are you most
excited to see from luke cage's journey
who else is crazy pumped for the
defenders let me know in the comments
below or shout out your thoughts to me
on Twitter and hey don't forget to
subscribe to et's YouTube channel bye
guys